we thought we'd show you a little couple
of videos here of things that are going
on in some of these wonderfully run
Democrat cities here's uh Los Angeles
over the weekend here's a bunch of
people attacking a gas station because I
guess getting Slim Jims over at Target
is a little too much for them
let's go into our Newsroom shows
hundreds of people crowding in ARCO near
Central and along
smashing the door dozens of looters
flooded into the store grabbing anything
they could La sheriff's deputies tell us
there were thousands of dollars worth of
merchandise stolen and a thousand more
in Damages this as deputies deal with
numerous Street takeovers throughout the
city deputies say they couldn't
intervene because of safety concerns as
they were very outnumbered only one
arrest
the guy taking the condoms did you see
that at the end he's just grabbing all
the real take the ribs I'll take the
lambskin I'll take the black one give me
the condoms as if anyone's having sex
with that guy like what are they doing
you're breaking just everything being
equal if you're one of these looters
what are you doing why are you breaking
into a gas station literally let me get
Doritos and sugar-free red ball
go to Target like you usually do your
map you might walk out of there with the
television what are you doing at a gas
station really thinking I'd like a
keychain
some windshield wiper fluid
you go to Target they have everything
they got kids toys you can get the
newest transformer you get a basketball
[Music]
idiots all right so that's Los Angeles
why a mob would be guys you want to
break into a gas station it just sounds
so idiotic but here's Chicago and now
Chicago plenty of people got killed this
weekend but we're just going to show you
a general chaos and remember they have a
new mayor this is not Lori Lightfoot but
they got someone even more radically
left than Lori Lightfoot which shows you
that uh you know there really is no end
to this thing here's just general chaos
of Chicago
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
are you on citizen or no I am
can you imagine being the one cop who
just drove down the street in the middle
of that thing like oh I was just looking
for a donut shop
I mean it's just utter Mayhem it looks
like the Reuben family Thanksgiving out
there I mean it's just chaos but this is
what they want and they will just get
more of it you must understand they will
just get more of it uh by the way
Walmart announced that they are closing
one of their main stores in Chicago over
the weekend and there were protests
against Walmart
[Music]
foreign